Each lesson in this course corresponds
to a chapter from my textbook,
Contemporary Health Informatics.
A link to purchase it at a discount
is in the instructor's notes.
I also strongly suggest you
subscribe to E-Health Beat,
a free, daily e-newsletter published
by the California Health Foundation.
Just reviewing it each day will give you
a good understanding of what's happening
in health care and health informatics.
There are also some other suggested
blogs and newsletters I recommend you
refer or subscribe to, in order to
enrich your learning experience.
You can find this
information in the text or
in the instructor's notes on this page.
And it will also be collected
in the course materials page.
Now let's get started.